Her low freak bitches.
It was the most brutal injury I've ever,
have you ever seen one of those before?
Have you ever seen a schoolgirl crushed?
No.
I actually had my skull fractured,
but not like that.
That was the one of the worst things I've ever seen.
How did your sculpture,
I got kicked in the back of the head and the guy had a steel plate and is a Shin
Guard in China.
What?
Any Shin Guard.
So we had a shin guard on with a steel plate in it.
Yeah.
I mean,
I didn't really think anything of it at the time,
you know,
this was what,
like 10 years ago,
you know,
we would just fight all everywhere,
anywhere or whatever,
you know,
and,
and not really think twice about it.
And I,
uh,
so I fought,
he kicked me in the back of the head.
I got dropped,
got up,
I ended up knocking him out,
fought again the very next day.
Um,
Wyatt,
yeah.
Not Knock this guy out to,
and then,
uh,
when we got back to the states,
like I was having headaches all the time and I just thought I had a bad
concussion,
you know,
but like to like,
almost like a month later I kept seeing these like flashes of light every,
anytime someone would ever touch me,
you know,
I'd be working with like little kids or girls and smaller people in just them
touching me.
I'd get this like jolt and it,
you know,
it was kind of freaking me out and I,
uh,
I was getting ready for another fight and,
I had to get my Mri or a cat scan.
I remember what it was.
And they're like,
yeah,
you got an inch and a half crack in the back of your skull.
And they're like,
I don't know why you're not a vegetable right now.
You should be there.
Like,
if you even hit that again,
it would probably kill you.
Doctors always say that though.
Yeah,
of course.
What was the last time you were fucking knocked out?
One more time.
I'm dead,
you know,
it was one inch closer to my spine.
I'd be dead.
It was,
it was,
it was pretty a rough thing to happen.
And I couldn't do anything other than hit the bag by myself for,
I don't remember how long it was still like it let it heal,
but,
but it,
it was a total,
just essentially at a close its own,
you know,
there's just like,
don't get hit,
you don't get hit.
And I was getting ready for a fight and I actually still tried to fight anyway.
But,
uh,
the doctor who,
the doctor who diagnosed it was the doctor for the fights.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Like,
do he can't fight,
get out of here.
How long after that was the fight?
After the diagnosis?
Uh,
like a week.
That's a cat fight with fucking edge.
That's just kind of the mentality I had coming up,
you know.
And how old were you at the time?
25.
So he just felt invulnerable?
No,
not really.
I mean,
my,
my mentality from the beginning has always been,
I'm going to fight as long as I'm breathing.
And you know,
I've gotten into fights with some of the worst injuries ever.
Broken hands,
broken,
broken skulls,
broken faces.
And that's just the way I came up.
You know,
like you're going to fight no matter what,
you're going to fight anyone,
anywhere,
anytime,
any weight class.
And that's how I was able to get as much experience as I did.
Yeah.
The scientific research and showed at the red cell generation can be accelerated
if it is.
So in those circumstances then science has to uh,
update the circumstances where their sales can be regenerated is like a,
in 24 hours,
the body is not able to adapt to the circumstances where there is a lack of
oxygen.
It is half the oxygen and last,
and we go and see altitude on Kilimanjaro,
like 20,000 feet at the top.
So had to save 15,000 feet.
The acclimatization,
the adaptation is not as fast in human bodies that we found his breathing
techniques and using the mind and that enabled us to accelerate that,
what they thought,
what signs is thinking that uh,
that it is arranged.
Autonomically so outside of our will and we cannot interfere,
we cannot intervene now.
Uh,
so we,
uh,
we'll showed it with uh,
like 30 people by the way past the January.
I did it with a person 76 years old without a prior mountaineering experience.
And he did it in 44 hours,
dude,
76.
Uh,
I mean it's a robust 76 year old,
but he was a good guy.
Yes.
That,
so over a couple of days his old life is dead,
really transferred.
So,
um,
let me ask you this.
So the standard model of what someone can do as far as how much red,
so red blood cells they can generate is observed and they thought that it was at
15,000 feet,
it became too difficult.
But you've shown that with your exercises and when your deep breathing
techniques that you can actually accelerate red blood cell count consciously or
at least not consciously through conscious action,
conscious action using the breath.
And what techniques are you using?
The same what we did last time,
but then adapted to while you are walking and when,
uh,
you know,
first sign of ams,
lack of oxygen in the hat means headache.
A EMS is acute mountain sickness and the first sinus headache and that means a
lack of oxygen inside the brain.
Normally we are not able to get the oxygen then at that moment inside the brain
to equal the balance that this balance,
the lack of oxygen.
And I've learned to just to do that.
So we tackled the problem and keep on,
uh,
able to perform in the extreme conditions even so through this technique of
taking these enormous deep breaths,
letting some of it out and then trying to refill and then letting some of it
out,
trying to refill,
letting some of it out.
And then you're,
you're forcing your body to forcing your lungs to constantly carry air.
Yes.
Uh,
that it is,
we use the lungs is the passage way,
but it gets into the lymphatic system.
It gets into the tissue.
You know what we just found with the university in a,
in Germany,
they found out that the devices that show that we have hundred percent,
uh,
blood saturation,
oxygen and the blood is not hundred percent.
We go more.
Yeah.
They found it out for the first thought was 100% blood saturation.
There's actually a higher level above that.
Yes.
And that's what I always sad,
but now it's uh,
it's like proofing
and that I,
you know,
for people listening that might be in one of those valleys,
it's like,
don't try to just get through it,
really ask,
you know,
why,
what can I learn from this?
That was my biggest thing is I stopped asking why is this happening to me?
And started asking,
what can I learn?
Yeah.
So instead of painting yourself as a victim,
you paint yourself with someone who is present in the moment and just,
okay,
I don't want to do this anymore.
Right?
Let's figure out what's going on.
Exactly.
And we don't,
a lot of times we don't have the tools and that's where things like life
coaching and personal development come in handy is quits.
We can go and get those tools instead of using our old coping mechanisms by like
being strong or overing,
overworking,
overdrinking over do you know,
jumping into a relationship like whatever it may be.
We,
we don't really learn how to deal with disappointment,
failure,
anger or shame,
any of those things.
And so we're kind of left to these quick fix devices that I think that's a big
reason addiction is such a problem is because we don't really learn how to
manage emotion and how to manage just appointment.
And so we go for that thing that makes us feel better in the moment.
But the problem is we have to keep upping the ante.
You know,
at first that one glass of wine does the trick,
but then you need to,
then you need three,
then need vodka,
whatever it may be.
And so,
I mean,
why I'm so passionate about what I do is,
first of all,
I never,
I never thought I could be happy.
Like I really didn't.
I thought that this,
you know,
I,
I was going to be depressed and I just was gonna constantly be looking for
something to fix me.
I never really,
truly thought this life that I'm living now what as possible.
Again,
externally,
things look fine,
but internally I'm talking about a totally different kind of experience and it's
only because of those like really awful moments.
I call them expectation hangovers that I was kind of desperate enough to let go
of my normal coping mechanisms and my trying to control everything.
It was like the ultimate and surrender truly of going okay.
Like I don't,
I don't know.
I need to find a different way to deal with this.
And that's really what has led me down the path that,
that I am today.
[inaudible].